you
my name is Michael Holsworth as Phillips
you guys in advance for giving me the
opportunity to for lack of better turns
drone on about drones for about a half
hour here today I'll briefly be covering
the part 107 guidelines the differences
between hobby flying and 107 commercial
flying different policies procedures and
my experience thus far in the industry
at any time if you guys have any
questions feel free to interrupt I don't
mind and I'm going to leave some time at
the end for questions and if any you
guys want to come up and check out the
bird up here please feel free alright
this first slide is gonna talk a little
bit about my journey thus far in the UAV
industry her UAS brought my first drone
in 2014 to take with me on a trip to
Hawaii edited up some footage posted my
content to YouTube and got a little bit
of semi viral success about 50,000 views
and then a a Licensing Company actually
reached out to me and said hey we want
to utilize some of your footage we want
to sell it and we like it and I just
said man I just made this for fun I can
make money doing this this is great and
a little side revenue stream there after
you know after I started making a little
bit of money I was kind of hooked and
when the first round of 107 exams took
place roughly two years ago I told my
father at East Coast I want to be the
very first person in the state to take
that exam I passed I was the first
person in the state of Massachusetts to
hold the 107 that reign of terror lasted
were roughly five minutes so the kid
next to me passed his test and then
there was two I then had some local
success next I made a video
Phillip was alluding to on Cape Cod over
at Wellfleet if any of you are familiar
with the Beachcomber I absolutely love
that place went and flew my drone there
posted a video all the local news
channels picked it up and about two
weeks later I received a nice $1,500
fine from the ranger station in Cape Cod
they fined me for what was it some kind
of piper
plover puffin bird out there I was
flying over a sanctuary they were not
happy
that and I was operating a UAS over a
national park I want to stress though
the FAA didn't find me it was the Ranger
service that fine that gave me the fine
I kind of chuckled at it because I made
about forty eight hundred bucks off the
footage and that made the fine I took
worth it in the fall of 2016 I basically
hit some viral gold
I took my drone up to the kanka Mancos
highway during the fall made a nice
little foliage video a couple licensing
companies picked it up and that very
next day it ran on Good Morning America
I got some national attention to the
tune of about 4.7 million views on the
video still counting people still
watching that thing all the time
especially in the fall gets a lot of
play you might be wondering what does
4.7 million views equate to in dollars
I'll admit it's not that much you'd
expect wish it was a buck of you but
unfortunately is not I think I made
about 10 grand off that but something I
was just doing for fun and made you know
I had no intention of it going viral or
getting that kind of success I was
definitely a plus
after I got that national attention a
local production company called above
summit here in Somerville contacted me
where you been all our lives come work
for us and now I'm a production
coordinator and lead drone up over at
above summit next slide this slide
basically just provides you with some
links to the full text of regulations
introduction material and any other
relevant documents you guys can take a
look at this on your own time alright
next we're going to talk a little bit
about hobby verse 107 let's talk about
the difference hobby operation is just
how it sounds you want to go out and
take some pictures of your kid or do
whatever that's that's on your own time
that's hobby but if your intended use is
for anything commercial you are required
to obtain a 107 some examples real
estate photos aerial surveying thermal
imaging search-and-rescue industrial
pipeline inspection things of that
nature even if you're working for or
with a non-profit you still have to
obtain
1:07 what are the what are the asterisks
there Michael I'm getting to it okay
we're getting there so some basic
operating rules are shared by both hobby
and 107 operators you have to keep
visual line of sight must follow basic
safety guidelines maintain altitude of
400 feet or below something to note like
Philip was saying you'll see these
asterisks bullet points on the
right-hand side under 107 you can get
waivers and exceptions from the FAA to
kind of break these rules we're gonna
talk a little bit more about that as the
slides continue here we'll circle back
to that slide for talks about multi
person crew you know they don't tell you
that you have to have a multi person
crew sometimes it's really not needed if
you're working for let's say a real
estate company and they want you to take
some photos of a residential house you
know you're standing right in front of
the house you don't really need a visual
observer someone looking for
obstructions or things of that nature
you can pull it off yourself but in more
of a professional setting or depending
on the scope of your job that you're
using your UAS for you know having a
visual observer is definitely helpful I
have some buddies that work in the
industrial sector inspecting pipeline
that's 30 40 miles long they actually
use ten visual observers and they stage
them with radios and binoculars along
the pipeline just for added safety and
then they have the the operator kind of
cruising you know walking with the drone
if you will sometimes but my personal
experience on movie sets and things of
that nature we operate with a three-man
crew we have a visual observer a camera
operator and then someone behind the
wheel of this thing right here you will
notice this camera on here can be
independently operated by its own set of
controls and then the drone can be
operated by its set of controls width
which allows you to get you know more
dynamic range of shots drone can be
going this way camera can be panning the
other way drone can be rising up as
camera goes down so it really brings
some versatility to your shots and
things of that
the last bullet point here mentions that
the drone operator need not be certified
but a 1:07 operator must be on site and
you might be wondering when this would
come into play I get a lot of requests
from wedding people wedding people
videographers photographers things of
that nature they look at the drone as
kind of another tool in their in their
bag to utilize when they're you know
doing their gigs and things of that
nature they don't want to get a 107 they
don't want to want the hassle for them
it's easier to pay me a hundred bucks
just to show up and make sure they're
doing everything on the up-and-up and
supervising it always amazes me - at
weddings why someone would want this
loud spinning machine over their
ceremony you know whether giving their I
Do's all your here's me some people
actually want it for the video that
wanted for Prosperity I guess all right
human factors in decision-making alcohol
and drugs obviously don't operate under
the influence no matter how tempting it
is have a couple beers want to fly on
the beach not a smart idea let's see
here crew resource management this
basically stated the more people you can
bring into the operation the better
nothing wrong with an extra set of eyes
fatigue and stress obviously not a good
time to operate here's one of my
favorites talking about attitudes the
FAA they list five attitudes
anti-authority macho impulsivity and
vulnerability and resignation the one I
see the most out there is anti Authority
all the time people want to fly where
they're not supposed to they want to fly
longer than they should they want to fly
in no-fly zones eight hundred feet by
Logan right by the runway you know
that's just not beneficial for the Hobby
not beneficial for anybody that Logan
example Logan is actually currently
doing something about it the company DJI
which Phillip mentioned earlier they're
actually you know the leader in
commercial drone systems they recently
came up
this product called DJI arrow scope and
what arrow scope does whether it's a DJI
drone or not if you fly into Logan
airspace it will ping your bird and it
will tell them your location and serial
number
the serial number is going to go right
back to you you're gonna lose your 107
and you're gonna get some hefty fines
it's just not smart to fly in Logan
airspace or any Airport airspace for
that example what why do you want to
mess around with the manned aircrafts
next we're gonna get into performance
you'll basically find the same
performance issues that you do with
fixed wings but you know the drone
obviously is going to be more sensitive
to these issues things like high density
altitude humidity weight high winds are
all examples items that are going to
negatively impact the performance of
your UAS so definitely be cautious of
that loading I always like talking about
this you know there is no book yet about
how to properly load these things now
this drone that I brought in you know
this this only has a limited amount of
camera and imaging systems that you can
mount here onto the drone so this camera
actually comes off this whole entire
three axis gimbal system here can mount
off and you can put interchangeable you
know if you wanted to put thermal let's
say let's say the police call me and
they they got somebody missing or
somebody kidnapped and they think
they're in this area I can do you know
grid patterns with thermal imaging to
find these guys so that's that's this
type of drone but when we're on movie
sets and things of that nature we're
using what the term we called is a heavy
lift drone we have a drone that has a
wingspan of about 10 feet from prop to
prop its massive it can hold up about
you know 40 to 50 pounds on its own
stabilizer and the problem is is that
there's so many different kinds of
cameras that this thing could mount you
could mount an Aria Lexi mini you could
mount
Hanan as Sony you know cameras that you
see people walking around the common
taking pictures with you can mount on
these types of drones the issue is
they're all different sizes they're all
different shapes they're all different
weights and there's no real book on how
to properly mount these things so what
we do is test test test we go out to
wide open fields you know what here's a
good example last month we did a movie
called knives out if any of you have
seen James Bond double-oh-seven that
actor Daniel Craig we were doing a movie
for that and they wanted this about
hundred thousand dollar camera mounted
onto the drone for the job if that's not
nerve-racking enough flying one hundred
thousand dollars but then we were
nervous we were like look we've never
flown that camera before we've never
tested it on this heavy lift drone so we
actually made the studio give us the
camera for a week we took it to a wide
open field we played around with it for
a while and you know we got it dialed in
perfectly I mean the last thing you want
to do is show up to a job and kind of
wing it with six figures worth of
equipment where you're working around a
guy gets paid twenty million dollars a
movie it's just a recipe for disaster so
make sure you're always testing all the
time especially if you're loading
different things you could definitely
have fun with loading these things up -
I was telling Phillip a story the other
day about five years ago when I had my
first DJI phantom I met I mounted some
Roman candles on the landing gear chase
my buddies around so you could
definitely have some fun there there's
nothing in the book about that moving on
drones at night you do need a waiver to
fly at night and we'll get more into how
to apply for these waivers and what
portals you have to go through with the
FAA the drone zone is actually for
flying at night and again I'll get more
into that you can however operate we
like using the term Golden Hour or civil
twilight if you will the only rule is
you have to have a small strobe or
anti-collision lights on there we always
like to mount on this drone right there
just to make sure we're not getting
anything in the camera image or you know
we don't want the footage to show the
strobe obviously but we want to play it
safe
Michael sir hold on SEC so is there is
there an official mounting spot for a
light here or you know you just have to
like velcro velcro it on a relative
interesting let's see here
regulatory fine print don't be careless
or reckless don't drop stuff if you
can't if you crash and it caused a
significant damage which I believe the
FAA considers $500 you do have to report
it
luckily I've never run into that issue
which is nice
pre-flight pre-flight is huge just like
fixed-wing you want to do pre-flight you
can see all the pre-flight requirements
here on the slide in my personal
experience I've seen situations go very
bad because pre-flight has not happened
literally three weeks ago I had a buddy
who bought the same exact drone and
actually was a version before this this
is a DJI inspire 2 he had a DJI inspire
1 it was very cold outside and he just
fired it up and took off right away
did not pay attention to his battery
voltage about 8 minutes into his flight
his bird dropped like a rock and that
was about a five thousand dollar loss
just going out having fun with your
buddies so pre-flight is definitely
something that you want to pay attention
to personally I double and triple check
before taking off a lot of times what I
do I'll you know do my walk-around the
drone to make sure everything's good
make sure connection links are fine and
then what I'll do when I take off I'll
let it sit for about 30 seconds right in
front of me 5 feet off the ground
watch the controls watch everything make
sure my gauges are right make sure I
have good connection to satellites make
sure it's GPS locked make sure my return
to home button is readily available and
marked it just these these are expensive
you know I mean this setup right here
you're looking at you know ten thousand
dollars into this thing so a little
extra time pre-flight is definitely
worth it
also remember pre-flight just doesn't
include only the drone as well if you're
working with a multi crew you know
double-check your comms
double-check your batteries double-check
the props make sure they're not chipped
things of that nature you know what this
reminds me of one story I actually did
have a crash once about three years ago
if you guys know what stand-up paddle
boarding is right people stand up on the
paddle board and they do this thing I
had a company asked me to film them at
night and marblehead and it was this big
open bay with a ton of boats so we had
like 40 yards of open water and then
nothing but a boat parking lot and these
guys at night we're gonna put LED strip
lights all over them
they had these spotlights to go under
the water on the board and they were
gonna do some nighttime blacklight yoga
session out there in the water sure if
your check clears I'll go film it no
problem all right so I say to myself all
right I'm looking at the situation and I
say all right there's a bunch of boats
out there I do not want to hit them it
is going to be night
I will not see them when I'm flying what
can I do so I walked up to where I was
gonna launch from dip my piggies in the
water right there and said all right I'm
gonna fly the drone out to the first
boat and I'm gonna look at my control
setup and I'm gonna note how far away I
am from the boats all right I think it
was 90 feet away so I told myself
mentally when it comes time to film this
at night I will not go past 90 feet or
I'm gonna hit a boat all right what do
you think the problem with that is
anyone anyone know what the problem with
that assessment is and I was a bonehead
I did not consider the tide so about two
hours later when it came time to do the
job I put my piggies in the same water
right there but guess where that water
was about 20 feet out all right so I'm
thinking to myself I got 90 feet to play
with about I don't know I want to say
one of my last shots I wanted to get I
had him all lined up all the lights
everything looked cool they're all doing
like a yay and I wanted to orbit around
them and halfway around my orbit I hear
crunch splash I hit a boat mast
luckily very luckily the drone hit the
mast the battery came out of the compar
and the batteries what I heard splashing
the physical drone and more importantly
the memory card with my footage landed
on the boat which one of the guys ended
up getting for me so that was good but
Michael quit yes quick question I
thought these drones had sonar so tight
collision system these do yeah so most
they most certainly do and quite frankly
between I don't want to endorse this you
should always fly with your you know
obstacle avoidance on and your vision
positioning sensors and things of that
nature for me personally it blows my
shots all the time so I turned them off
I say you know if this is a tip of a
house right and I want to go over the
house and reveal what's behind it but I
want to make it look cinematic and I
want to clip that roof real close and
then you know reveal when I'm revealing
too many times I try to clip it close at
a bbbb beep no you can't your shots now
bloom so I always I personally I turn
them off right for beginners I'd
recommend do not turn them off fly with
them on until you're very comfortable
with these things again they're not
cheap they're expensive so a consumer in
that boat situation the term wouldn't
have hit the boat because the
anti-collision system would have if I
had it on that perhaps if I had it on
correct you know you'll notice you know
on the drone these this is a this is
obstacle avoidance this is obstacle
avoidance right there it's got visioning
position system on the back and an
obstacle avoidance on the back as well
so it's got they like to say they're
idiot proof you know unless you turn
everything off next slide we're going to
talk a little about about operating
locally here in the Boston area in order
to fly commercially in the Boston area
you have to be 107 and you must obey we
call it the grid that ATC @kb OS created
and you know what let's just take a look
at the grid here so you'll notice on
this grid this is the local Boston area
every little square there has a number
that number represents the height that
you can achieve if you obtain the waiver
and you also have to be 107 certified to
fly in this grid
you can do hobby flights if you you know
theoretically you're supposed to call
the tower if you're doing a hobby flight
and and make them aware that you're
gonna be flying in the airspace in my
personal experience every time I've
called no one picks up you leave a
voicemail but if you are flying
commercially and you are 107 certified
you do need to pay specific attention to
this grid for example if I wanted to fly
in Boston Common you can see right in
that area there's there's a hundred box
there so without a waiver since I'm 107
certified I am allowed to fly a hundred
feet in the common if I hold the
authorization to do so and we're gonna
get more into you know when do you go
through the drone zone and when you go
through lank and we'll talk about that
in a second here any questions about the
grid anyone theoretically if you're a
hobby flyer they tell you have to be 400
feet or below so in theory if you called
Logan and said hey I'm flying in the
common today and I just wanted to let
you know I'm just doing it for fun and
and messing around theoretically you
could fly 400 feet is that smart
no because what's going on around there
med flights helicopters things of that
nature ton of people underneath I see it
all the time I mean I'll be and walk
down the public garden or whatever and
you'll see people taking off their drone
flying around like an idiot having a
grand old time and I'm just thinking
myself all it's going to take is for you
to hit someone you're gonna be on every
news station tonight you know and
alright let's get into a little bit of
the waiver process there's two portals
for waivers and authorizations one's
called the drone zone and one's called
length the drone zone is used for night
flights wide area authorizations and
exceptions such as those a strict items
that we were looking at earlier like
flying over people flying from a moving
vehicle flying over
400 feet flying at night things of that
nature and also the drone zone is meant
for wide area authorization so I hold a
bunch of wide area authorizations that
whole grid that you saw I basically
applied for the entire grid so I applied
through the drone zone said hey FAA I
work commercially in the area I don't
want the pain in the butt of having to
go through the Lange system every time I
get a job just give me the entire grid
and that's good for two years now the
difference is lank is same-day
authorization so let's say I get a job
in Chicago where I'm not always
operating out of and I noticed that the
address they gave me in Chicago has a
little box around it it's Class D
airspace and they say I can only go 200
feet well if I don't hold a waiver for
Chicago then I would use the length
system just to get authorization for
that one box that I'm operating in for
that specific day in time they will give
that to you within 24 hours
now for the wide area authorizations or
if you wanted to fly at night or over
the grid box if they say hey you can
only fly a hundred but you say hey the
building I want to film is over 200 I
need 300 feet or something of that
nature you have to go through the drone
zone now the problem with the drone zone
is that it's a two to four month waiting
time so it always behooves you
especially if you're gonna work in your
local market to get these authorizations
beforehand I don't know anyone that's
going to offer you a job for months in
advance and for months I want you to
film you know this down the street here
usually these things happen pretty fast
so it always behooves yourselves to get
all your authorizations and get all your
waiver is kind of in line next slide
here we're going to talk about the
certificate basically stated read the
regs study up take the test
you know personally with my affiliation
with the East Coast Aero Club they have
a great testing center and great people
over there so please make sure you go
East Coast Aero Club slide 16
certification for traditional pilots
take an online course apply through AI
Accra
and you're off and running or flying as
they say slide 17 for you guys in this
class you do have a couple options any
private pilot license holders out here
anyone hey alright
private pilot's license no exams really
required if you do not hold a private
pilot's license
you must schedule your 107 exam at your
local testing center slide 18 we're
getting back to the Hobby and 107 we
highlighted some of these asterisk arias
here can talk about these a little bit
more you know this is all about the
power of the waiver you know for example
about six months back the Discovery
Channel was down here and they asked us
to do they had a restored Viking ship
and they were taking that Viking ship
from Nova Scotia and sailing it down the
East Coast and the Discovery Channel was
doing this big documentary show about it
and you know how the journey went the
problems that they ran into but for me
the problem I was running into is I have
to fly from a boat which is a moving
vehicle I had to be over 400 feet and
they wanted some of those shots at night
right luckily we had all these waivers
in place if not we would have had to
tell them hey it's gonna take two to
four months for us to get these waivers
and they would have went to the next
company so it always pays to have these
waivers and authorizations in place
this is embarrassing slide 19 is some of
the recent accomplishments and projects
that I've been working on a few a-list
names up there you know locally what I
can say locally in this market is we
have seen a major spike in TV and movie
productions being made in New England
specifically in Massachusetts it's been
great for us which is fantastic keeps us
extremely busy which is great
hiring gigs are fun they are lucrative
as well
the problem is there there is a lot of
pressure you know when I was doing the
equalizer to movie I mean we're flying
we actually use this drone right here
and you know they wanted me to fly the
thing over Denzel Washington shoulder
you know what I'm saying to myself man
one gust of wind or mistake I could
slice this guy's face open so there is a
lot of pressure associated with it
directors and and you know DPS directors
of photography they want things done the
first time time is money I mean imagine
if you were you know there's one time
where I was chasing a motorcycle and
there were some explosions going off it
took six hours to rig those explosions
they're only going to go off once
if you mess the shot up it's going to
cost them another 6 Brenda rigged up
it's going to take half a day of time to
do it again so there's a lot of pressure
to get it done right the first time but
generally you know these jobs are few
and far between the primary jobs that we
usually do marketing and promotional
videos you know documentaries things of
that nature can be a little less
pressure but once you get into the upper
epsilon of doing feature films and
things of that nature it's you know be
on your a-game alright a little bit
about life on set higher end productions
you can expect about 2k a day per
operator which is lovely you know even
even the visual observer making sure
that we're not hitting power lines or
things of that nature I mean the guy's
just looking up and paying attention
he's making a great day's pay there but
again there there is a lot of pressure
that 2 grand per day I need to note too
that
that's not including gear rental
insurance and media rental and
everything else that comes along with it
so you know I work for a company called
above summit as I mentioned here in
Summerville you know they're usually
charging twenty thirty thousand dollars
a day when we're on a movie that's just
a little piece of what the operators see
we generally work in a three-man crew
when you're on TV and movies it can be
extremely humbling as well a lot of
times you you know will nail a shot the
director will love it everyone will say
oh that's great you did such a great job
then the TV show comes down you're like
where's my footage they don't use it
sometimes you know and you get kind of
bummed out about it so it can be a
humbling experience
you could spend weeks and hours on set
flying creating footage getting them
content and barely any of it will be
used I was talking earlier about the
equalizer movie with Denzel that I did
seven days on set got him roughly two
hours of raw footage and about seven
seconds made the final movie I loved the
seven seconds but wish there was a
little bit more what was the 12 days on
set - 12 seconds in the final cut which
movie was that oh I think yeah that was
the equalizer when maybe it was 12
seconds not seven when why bring and why
bring a book um um yeah there you go
there buddy
the bring a book thing don't don't
literally bring a book cuz you just look
pretty silly that the main point of the
bring a book thing is it's extremely
boring you got to remember the whole
movies not made with this thing they're
generally doing action sequence with the
drone tracking shots establishing shots
you know top down where you're high up
and the cameras pointed straight down
things of that nature but there's about
30 other camera
you know equipment and people out there
they're also getting their shots their
ground shots and things of that nature
which does take up the bulk of the movie
or TV show or whatever so I have found
there have been times that I've been on
set 1214 hours and I've only flown this
thing maybe 10 20 minutes so there is a
ton of downtime that's you know hence
the bring a book
and sometimes it can be disappointing
last year we did a pilot TV show for NBC
called suspicion it was a very fun shoot
they had a stunt guy getting dragged on
the back of a Cadillac Escalade and we
got to track it and film it and we just
got some incredible footage some
incredible shots everyone was super
happy the show wrapped the first couple
episodes of the pilot it gets sent off
to NBC a bunch of guys in suits were
there and they said yeah we hate this
and it just got scrapped altogether and
the good part is their checks still
cleared but you know we're not seeing
any of that work you know what that's
about it for me how do I click this link
to get to work
Phil asked me to string together some
footage that I've taken personally so
you guys can kind of see the drone in
action all the footage you're gonna see
here actually was not done with this
drone this is more of a professional
drone this was all done with a DJI
phantom this is a drone that you could
you know literally pick up at BestBuy
for like a thousand bucks I like having
it just because it's you know you can
throw it in them in the back of your car
and have around if you ever see
something fun to go out in the film you
have it there questions questions yeah
guys hit me with some questions while
this thing's playing anybody got any
questions for me if anyone wants to come
up and play with this thing or take a
look at it feel free but
this is roan right here dual battery
system so you'll notice it's got two
cool thing about this particular system
self-induced heating batteries which is
great in the wintertime you know cold
equals bad battery voltage so with these
things you know heating and going that's
great
in regards to like range if you're
wondering about range this and go a mile
up in four miles out all right do I want
to do that no huh
time estimated time twenty two minutes
to twenty four depending on load and how
aggressive you're flying it you know if
I'm if I'm in this thing has something
called sport mode or you know ludicrous
mode whatever you want to call it that
you can get this thing up to like eighty
and it's gonna suck the juice out of the
batteries real quick if you're you know
thrusting full throttle for a while but
if you're just hovering it could get
twenty five twenty six minutes back to
the range thing yes this thing can go a
mile up in four miles out I never like
to do that I look at this thing as a big
bag of money alright
you want your money close to you you
want it four miles out where you can't
have your eyes on it you know you'd be
surprised a lot of people do like doing
that they call it range testing I call
it stupidity
you know let's see how far we can send
the thing before it it has a battery
failure you know before it auto lands
you know not something I like to screw
around with personally should be up now
anyone else sir
[Music]
yes anything you're gonna make money or
promote yourself 1:07 if it just think
to yourself if I'm just out having fun I
don't need a 107 they do need to be 107
or and a 107 operator has to you know
you could hire a guy like me to just be
there and say hey you're doing
everything on the up-and-up make sure to
read back the question cuz oh I'm sorry
the video yeah that's fine got anybody
else
[Music]
this is what we do so in a lot of our
contracts you know when we when we get
initially approached by like columbia
pictures or lionsgate or something of
that nature they'll send us a volume you
know of their contract and what we're
allowed to do with the footage what
we're not you know it's almost like an
NDA as well you can't post
behind-the-scenes stuff you can't kind
of blow yourself up on social media or
things of that nature
sometimes we put verbage in there that
says hey after we say we want to use the
footage for our own personal promotion
what they generally come back and say is
you can do that after the the movies
come out right they don't want you
promoting something that they don't get
first dibs of promoting first so after
the movies released usually you give it
like a month grace period you know that
in between period before it's on Netflix
or DVD but it's out of the theater then
we usually feel comfortable to you know
kind of self promote with that footage
anybody else are you guys all mesmerized
by drone fine look at that that was
actually Big Island Hawaii right there
that's local that's in West Boylston I
tell people that my dream is to get as
good footage out of a four hundred
thousand dollar helicopter as a person
can get out of a four hundred dollar
drone the helicopter guys absolutely
hate us we are stealing their market
share you know exponentially are the
movie studios do they want to hire they
have to hire the photographer the pilot
the fuel the time the cost all that or
they want to hire us at a third of a
cost and we're gonna get better more
dynamic footage so the doing it out of
helicopters is is going to the wayside
everyone's kind of going to these
machines now yeah so Michael said this
was about ten thousand dollars including
the camera there's just a piece of metal
that's FA certified through a
supplemental type certificate called the
Tyler amount and you just connect this
to your helicopter any landing gear or
something and then put the camera on
this piece of metal and I think that
piece of metal you know the cheapest
ones I've ever seen are about twelve
thousand dollars so just a piece of
metal that has
through the approval process and all the
paperwork costs more than the entire
drone system in the camera balls can be
in the 4 or 5 $600,000 range that go
underneath helicopters Robinson actually
makes a cool news copter it's all FAA
certified right from the factory think
it's in a million dollar range if it has
the ball and the camera and the
transmitter back to the TV station but
as Michael said you know do we really
need those in the drone age ya know
generation of drones what capability is
what I like to see
I'm currently right now talking to a
bunch of people that I guess not
capability but they're doing a lot with
augmented reality and I think you're
gonna see a lot of that coming out I'm
sure you guys have heard of it I'm gonna
sound really nerdy here but pokemons go
you know on your cell phone and you can
see the little Pokemon guys running
around and now imagine if I wanted to
train somebody on how to properly fly a
drone then I could you know put these
rings or circles or maybe directions on
the screen when they're flying to kind
of go through the hoop and you know make
a figure eight or things like that so I
think we're gonna see a lot of kind of
augmented reality stuff coming in and
and things of that nature also they're
making them smaller that's another big
thing and they're making them more
diverse with image systems what you can
mount you know being able to mount
something smaller more powerful they
have cameras now that have hundred times
zoom on one end of the camera and then
on the other end they have thermal so
you can switch back and forth between
the two on the same drone so things of
that nature kind of making it more
efficient and battery time as well
that's a big thing people want drones
that are going to you know fly for hours
not minutes so I think you're gonna see
a big push in that
[Music]
this is it these are controllers I'll
level with you if any of you guys have
ever played first-person shooter games
on PlayStation it's about the same right
one remote for the pilot one remote for
cam op so it's the same remote basically
it's the same principle if you're
playing a first-person shooter left and
right on the joystick a camera operator
and and drone operator get the same
physical remote correct okay
correct it's that answer the question
for you well
so thank you thank you for reminded that
the key word there's autonomy so there
are different programs now I don't use
them personally a lot because my
applications more cinematic and doing
things of that nature which I like to
fly manually there's more you know
feathering and kind of finesse to that
but a lot of people that are doing
Industrial right like like surveying and
things of that nature this thing's as
powerful as it gets there's a program
called lychee that you can attach to
this drone that you'll you can run off
there they're operating platform you can
put waypoints in and say all right go to
point a at 50 feet snap a photo then go
20 feet up go to the right a hundred
feet then take a video and then go down
you know so you can pre-program these
things a lot of my buddies do it they
make great money and all they do is they
they program the grid into the drone
they hit go and then they sit back and
they watch the thing do the job for them
you know and there is there's great
money in the industrial sector with
these things with autonomous flights and
things of that nature
the only time I've ever used waypoints
is to do something called a hyperlapse
if anyone knows about photo or video a a
time-lapse is something when you take a
photo then you move the camera take a
photo move the camera take a photo a
hyperlapse is when you include motion in
something like that Waypoint feature is
great we put a waypoint at point a and
then you know 300 feet away we point
point B and we say every two seconds
from A to B take a photo and go to this
straight line then we string all the
photos together and you get like a cool
little hyperlapse effect so sometimes we
use the autonomy honestly the enjoyment
is for me is flying manually I don't
want to just enter in a bunch of data
and say okay go do your job
I'd rather be on the controls and you
know having fun with it so hope that
answers your question sir
some guys studio again who did the
industrial kind of stuff yes they'll
they'll utilize the the functions for
autonomy but again personally I just
don't I like flying we hated Michael
that literally is how comfortable you
are with it some people I know never
take the the obstacle avoidance off they
think it's there for a reason they don't
need to get that really tight clothes in
shot a lot of people just do hi and what
we call high and wide you know you just
fly the thing up 300 feet you get a nice
landscape view or whatever you're
looking for and you have the collision
on for that or whatever but again I mean
you probably saw some of those close
shots I had in that video though you
can't have you can't obtain that with
the with the avoidance system on me
personally I think within three weeks I
turned him off man that was I guess not
for me I just want to jam on the thing
and get some great footage so you know
the safety wasn't impeding it a little
bit for me right it can fly well over
400 feet but you're only allowed to fly
up to 400 feet the funny thing is like
why do you want it though I mean well
why do you want to be three feet off the
ground risking your you know a couple
thousand dollar piece of equipment when
you could just take a handheld camera
and walk you know I mean you saw in some
of the shots there I'm skimming waves at
a foot you know foot off the way of
skimming them so yeah you you can fly
really low again you you have to have
your sensors off for that though you're
the the sensor systems that are on these
things will say what are you doing idiot
don't don't fly me like this you know so
in order to achieve it you have to shut
them off
so if you're like reading often rather
than your neighbors back there the
yeah that's a slippery slippery slope
the privacy laws and things of that
nature I mean a lot of the bad press
that drones get you know like oh I was
sunbathing in my backyard a night and I
saw a drone you know way up in the sky
and they're invading my privacy and it's
just like well really think about that
you look like a little ant and like how
much privacy am I really invading you
know handheld cameras with telescopic
lens are gonna invade more privacy than
this thing is some I think it's an
evolving legal area like that and it's
the classical law has been that the
airspace belongs to the public only the
FAA can regulate it but that's been
eroded I think a few states have been
passing you know anti-drone laws they've
been trying the various kind so I don't
think it's a I think it's untested legal
area there's a question over here I
don't know the acronym what's the
acronym ESP yeah fixed-wing has to have
ATS be installed by 2020 so they're
they're cure the question was our drones
gonna have to have them the problem with
it right now is they don't make them
lightweight and small enough to equip on
these things when they do in the
technologies they're I'm willing to bet
you're gonna see it yeah absolutely
the problem is the weight you know you
can't you can't throw that extra weight
and get any kind of you know viable
performance out of it with them right
now but as the technology gets better
and they make those things smaller I'm
willing to bet you're gonna see them on
every single one yeah
very slow for me aerials sir great
question great question I've seen so
many people crash they're grown because
they are I call them screen warriors
alright they're there they got their
control here and they got their iPad
mounted and they can see everything in
there oh my god this is so great
boom they hit a tree why why did they
hit the tree because the camera right
now this drones a little bit different
when this drone takes off this landing
gear actually raises up above the body
here so this camera down here can spin
360 without getting the legs in the
footage or anything of that nature but
your general consumer drone when you're
looking at your iPad when you're flying
right you're seeing what the camera sees
which is great but what you're not
seeing is your peripheral right you're
not you're not seeing that your props
are out this this far and if you're just
sitting there looking at the screen
you'll you'll end up clipping something
you'll end up doing something my general
rule of thumb if I'm flying by myself I
set up a shot I look at the screen a lot
of times though and this just comes with
experience I know what the cameras I can
look at the drone know what the cameras
seeing and a professional setting that's
why you have a multi person crew while
you have a visual observer because a lot
of the times when you're getting paid
and you're under pressure and time
crunch to get the shot your head needs
to be dug into that screen and that's
why you need radio communication with a
visual observer to say hey you're clear
no obstruction 25 yards have at it or
you know whatever whatever the case may
be but flying for fun by yourself my
advice would be look up at your bird
every now and again
I've also had people that have flown and
then been like wait where is it you know
because again these things can go a mile
up in a mile out and all the sudden
they're like wait a second where'd my
drone go now luckily for lack of better
terms and excuse my language I call it
the oh [ __ ] button but there's a button
right here so when I turn the drone on
what it does is it communicates the
satellites it marks a GPS home point
right now if I'm being an idiot and I'm
sending it out you know a mile away the
drone is smart enough to say hey I only
have enough battery percentage to get
back to your home point and it will kick
me off the controls all together and it
will fly itself back and land right
where you took off same function as
where'd my drone go I can't find it if I
really need it to you hit that button
and the thing will fly itself back now
if you utilize that function but this is
getting back to the sensors and things
of that nature if you have your sensors
turned off you're in trouble
right because what the drone is going to
do is take its most direct path back to
your home point if there is a building
in a way it will hit the building if
your sensors are off now if your sensors
are on like I actually have this setup
to where if return to home function
kicks in the sensors turn on right and
then I also have it set up to where if
it meets an obstruction let's say
there's a building here oh no I don't
know where my drone is I hit return to
home and it comes towards the building
it will sense it and will raise altitude
until it clears it and then it'll clear
it and continue on back to the home
point I never like to rely on return to
home though never I just I don't feel
comfortable with it I like knowing again
using the bag of money situation he's at
I don't want it to get away from me
again I mean you guys can come up and
pick this thing up it has some weight to
it
if this thing fell 400 feet and hit
somebody they're in trouble you are in
trouble so it behooves you to always
have set of eyes on it and you know pay
attention to everything you're doing
there
you